This hour, following developments in Ukraine
where a top commander says the country 'S
air defense forces intercepted 18 missiles
of various types across the country overnight.
In Kyiv, one official says that the capital
was a target of a exceptional complex air
assault involving drones and cruise missiles.
Local officials saying aired fences intercepted
the vast majority of the incoming strikes.
But falling debris has been reported across
several districts.
Wagner group chief of Ghana progression is
denying a Washington post report which says
he offered to give Ukraine information on
Russian troop positions in exchange for Kyiv
pulling back its forces from the area around
bakhmut.
Story based on U.S. Intelligence documents.
Leaked on social media in April.
Further alleging prigozhin made the offer
to Ukrainian military intelligence officers
during a
[4:14:49 AM]
intelligence officers during a meeting in
an unspecified African country.
Prigozhin has speculated the store might be
planted by his enemies.
I'm on the latest developments in Ukraine
we are joined by Chris Sebastian.
A real assault.
Overnight >> A huge night.
Mainly for Ukrainian air defenses which according
to commander of the armed forces who came
at himself, with this news shutdown all 18
of these missiles launched in the sea, air
and land.
And crucially, max including missiles which
are much hyped by Russia.
They call them hypersonic.
They actually just ballistic missiles.
But previously, even a few months ago, Ukraine
was saying they had nothing could intercept
these missiles.
Then several weeks ago, her day Tuesday patriot
battery to intercept one of them.
The uk's defense minister called this an unbelievable
[4:15:50 AM]
called this an unbelievable success for the
Ukrainian air defense forces and this is likely
to change the calculus from Russia, they do
not want to waste their missiles if they're
gonna get shot, down especially in what was
previous thought to be unstoppable Ukraine,
and especially going into an upcoming counteroffensive,
it must trailed counteroffensive where Ukraine
has warned that one of Russia's tactics is
to treat wear down your defenses.
>> It's interesting to see how they used those
offensive so tactically.
Explain in layman's terms what this deal was.
>> The key thing to know about this is, certainly
according to the sources, speaking the Washington
post, we have not independently confirmed,
this there is no deal made.
They did not take him seriously, they do not
trust, him and they did not make a deal with.
Him but he was essentially trying, according
to -- eastern eye this obviously, but the
report was that that he was trying to steal
where you give up some ground in bakhmut and
then you have a position, of the Russian armed
forces.
If it is true, and of course he has denied
it, it smacks of an element of sabotage by
[4:16:51 AM]
element of sabotage by prigozhin.
It goes a step further from the disruption
and inviting that we have seen so far.
We do not know what the truth is, but it certainly
does not
Turning now to the war in Ukraine, officials
say overnight the country was hit with 18
missiles of various air land and sea base
types.
In Kyiv, city official says the capital was
hit by an exceptionally dense attack involving
uavs, cruise missiles and likely ballistic
missiles as well.
Clare Sebastian is live in London.
Kyiv's air defense was able to knock most
or all of these out of the sky?
>> Reporter: Yeah, it was clearly an epic
night for the Ukraine air defenses.
According to the head of the armed forces
himself, they were able to shoot down all
18 that were launched at Ukraine from air,
land and sea, including as well six ballistic
missiles much touted by the ministry of defense,
Kremlin even by Vladimir Putin himself as
part of their next generation of
[5:09:44 AM]
of their next generation of weapons.
And previously even just a few months ago
Ukraine had said that they had nothing that
could intercept that kind of missile.
Just over a week ago they claimed they had
shot down one of them using a patriot battery
which U.S. Officials later told CNN that very
missile was targeting the patriot battery
and instead the patriot battery managed to
shoot it down.
So we don't know what were the targets, if
the patriot batteries were in play, but clearly
this shows that with the help of the western
weapons, Ukraine's air defenses are becoming
more effective and that may change the calculus
a little bit for Russia.
We know that this is
ahead of a possible counteroffensive.
But when air defenses can shoot
Another terrifying night in Kyiv as missile
defense systems swat down 18 different kinds
of bombardments from Russia.
And the men of Ukraine are ordered to fight
and women are stepping up and filling traditional
male only jobs.
Some of them come with inherent dangers.
But these women are doing courageous work
without hesitation.
Nic Robertson has more.
>> Reporter: In a man's world, War is changing
everything.
Tatiana is at the vanguard, shattering Ukrainian
coal mining history, a woman on her way to
work 1,000 feet underground.
Normal, it is okay now?
>> Yes.
>> You like it?
>> I love it.
>> You wanted to be a miner.
>> Yes.
[5:30:06 AM]
>> Your family, your grandfather, your father
was a miner.
>> Yeah.
>> Reporter: She used to work above ground.
But when miners got called up to fight and
martial law cleared women for dangerous job,
she jumped at a job team in the mine.
>> Translator: I always wanted to work here.
But girls were not allowed.
When many men were constricted, the mine had
to keep working.
So to protect our country, the girls stepped
up.
>> Reporter: She works six hour shifts, three
days on, one day off.
Earns more than previously.
And wants to keep her underground job when
the war is over.
>> Translator: My work is not physically difficult.
I like it a lot.
I would like to continue working here.
>> Reporter: In this bastion of male dominated
tradition, that may not be so easy.
>> Translator: I think when the war is over
and when we win, I think women will return
above
[5:31:08 AM]
think women will return above the ground and
do woman's jobs.
>> Reporter: Yesterday even this chief engineer
admits without Tatiana and many other women,
the mine could not have kept going.
>> Our miners got called up to fight and our
women wanted to help the mine and the country.
So far 46 women are working under the ground
now.
>> Reporter: There is plenty of traditional
male only workplaces are finding women stepping
up and taking jobs that before the war would
have only gone to men.
Maria is among them.
For the love of Ukraine and of her husband.
>> Translator: I knew the theory but the practice
turned out to be a little harder.
>> Reporter: She took up his blacksmith job
when he got called up to fight last year.
They bought the forge together a few years
earlier, invested
[5:32:09 AM]
few years earlier, invested their future in
it.
>> Translator: This is my husband's passion
and his life's business.
I decided to support him to keep his job alive
while he is serving.
>> Reporter: She shows me a video of her husband
Andre working at the same anvil pre-war, his
artwork selling in the U.S.
And Europe for hundreds ofe she is focusing
on simpler stuff.
>> Translator: I very often cry in the forge
here.
My husband is defending us and it is very
dangerous.
But this work helps me to hold on and not
fall apart.
>> Reporter: Women have been here before.
Remember Rosie the riveter?
Icon of women at work in world War II.
She and others cracked the glass ceiling.
More than a hint of Rosie in Maria and perhaps
of changes
[5:33:10 AM]
Maria and perhaps of changes here too.
>> Translator: It is tiring work but interesting.
I would like to do it when I feel like it,
not when I have to do it.
>> Reporter: Maria, Tatiana, two of many who
bravely stepped up no doubt more challenges
ahead.